what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude this [ __ ] is getting gay bro today
sorry
i got it it's just very dick oriented
today i wouldn't say it's gay well it's
that time of year it's spring
people are refreshed it's spring it's
the middle of the winter yeah it's
freezing cold out it's just
january whatever you guys don't know you
guys aren't open-minded
that's what i think it doesn't get more
winter than january
not even a groundhog's day yet why don't
i just say it's august okay
look here's gonna be fine listen i'll be
honest with you
i'm kind of [ __ ] in that
because i'm not gonna be that guy
whereas happy wife happy life oh those
guys are done
i watch whatever tv she wants to watch
i'm envious of them are you those cause
they have the smoothest [ __ ] life
never lose their house they're just like
this they're like a [ __ ] uh
you know those big doorman buildings
where i got a package for you mr robin
like you become that in the relationship
you should just say we're like the bell
cap
and something like that um
yeah see if i had the temptation i could
do whatever i want this is my big chance
everyone says brody you're gay you're
gay
i know it's eight now i'm in a room
in thailand and you're like i'll show
you making fun of brodie
and you know what i don't need to go
into detail
but i pushed it to the limit
i went as far as i could go
okay did i perform i will go on record
saying
no i did not never have don't want to
perform oral on a man can i go on record
saying that i got you but what what
happened
well that didn't happen okay
okay what didn't happen also is kissing
kissing didn't i don't want to kiss a
man let's be clear
there was no kissing no kissing no race
car driving
no meteorite impact many other things
didn't do
you make it unromantic
[Laughter]
go back to that vest story man so here's
what happened
so i you know i would get i would do
some cocaine a thousand put on these
different vests
how many did you buy again i don't know
i spent too much on them but
i would probably say the
priciest one i had was probably about
210 dollars nice damn yeah
and so i would get [ __ ] up and put
these vests on and put on sunglasses and
not
no like buffalo bills [ __ ] but at least
partying by myself you know
and one time i was making a smoothie you
know because i you know i have
i got like a new i don't know what kind
of blender it is but it's pretty nice
and i was making like a nice smoothie
and i'm [ __ ] coked up i'm partying
you know i'm living high on the hog
two vests on maybe right and i thought i
thought i
heard something outside right which is
kind of weird to even think of
when you have a blender going right so i
leave out of my apartment to go in the
hallway
lock myself out with the blender going
2 30 in the morning coked up out of my
brain right now i have to go to my
landlord dude
who lives right down the hall oh no and
tell him like hey man
in the morning i got locked out and the
blend is on
oh my god he must have hated you oh the
blender shorts out and
smoke happens the fire alarm starts
going off in the building
right as i'm at his door knocking right
oh my god so now he's pissed and he's
like what's going on
and i didn't know what to say i told him
that i was throwing a late
christmas party dude it was [ __ ]
into january how old was you at the time
huh oh this is two and a half years ago
[Laughter]
so he comes back to my apartment right
he's [ __ ] pissed
he unlocks the door there's nobody in
there
oh my god like man but that's a it was
fun
oh my no god was fun
how long did you live there for i still
live there
whoa yeah we've passed out you know like
i've caught him doing some things
i think we're all leaving joey told me
one time that uh he was
about [ __ ] in the shower and he was
like yeah it was great i did all the
time i was like he's [ __ ] here
she sit in the shower and he's like yeah
he goes
like if it's like a log i just [ __ ] and
then i just toss it
to the toilet and i was like oh my gosh
he said he said that how much practice
does he have to do with that well i
don't know you must have missed before
a piece of paper you go yeah the can you
miss
oh missing that he's missing would be so
bad he said that i go use did you stop
that's so [ __ ]
revolting did you he goes he's like i
had to go
why because my wife saw me do it one
time and she said
no more no no no more me too
with [ __ ] in their hand like [ __ ] oh my
god it's hilarious
dude i have i have sometimes with my
stomach i told this to tom a long time
on our
go on our podcast i took a [ __ ] in japan
once that was so bad
the guy in the stall next to me threw up
a joke we were in japan i thought he was
talking to me
he's like i'm like i don't know what
you're saying
no no japanese dude by the way
that's happened twice it happened once
in denver oh my humor is different
falling makes me laugh i don't care who
you are falling
makes me laugh i don't give a [ __ ] who
you are if you
fall in front of me no shot i'm holding
it laughing
there's no shot there's no shot you
don't stand a chance
if you fall in front of me there's no
shot that i'm not bust your ass
something something's got to come out
right falling is funny
i still think i it's hacky i still think
farts are funny when my kids fart i
laugh i still until this day it's the
funniest [ __ ] ever to me
nah it comes out but you stink get out
of here stay gas
my little son 17 months when he fart i
laugh
something something within just the
ability to just be
[ __ ] silly and stupid oh yeah it
doesn't always have to have a meaning
behind it some [ __ ] is just stupid my
eight-year-old farts on cue
she thinks it's hilarious she'll tell
you listen i gotta talk to you about
something
that's it they go and she starts
laughing she thinks it's hilarious
she'll fall down the couch the best
thing in the world she can't stop
laughing it's the best thing in the
world that's what you talking about as a
kid that's all you got
that's your only bit as a kid you got
nothing else but farts that's all you
got
that's all you got to make people laugh
you should enjoy it
yeah it should i still think it's funny
falling but falling is number one for me
falling is number one my wife fell down
the steps she got so mad
because i didn't rush to help her i
laughed
she had a wine glass wine was all over
the walls
oh my god one of the worst falls i've
ever seen in my damn life
got up her shoe was on one step the
other shoe was all
following funny how how could you be
michael jordan
and kids run up to you and say you're
the crybaby face
you cry man they're going to cry man
memes are like the best thing on the
internet it's one of the best things
about the internet it's the people being
able to make funny
it's the best thing but watch this
though it once it sticks
that's what i'm saying once it sticks
yeah i mean
michael jordan to somebody under the age
of 18
he to cry babyface man hey man they're
going to cry
hey man and then you know how uh uh you
know how fans do i mean cry right quick
dog
[Laughter]
let me get you crying it's so true have
you seen king ash rippers work
um excuse me
yeah harry and gross
lord of all farts and gluttony he makes
videos oh
no of him this is him yeah king asked oh
please give me some volume
that's still
look how brown is good back there
my stomach hurts my grandmother
like moans like she's she's hurt so bad
she can't move
she had an aneurysm 12 years ago so
she's just lying in bed like
so from the aneurysm on she was in just
paying all the time
she's done she was done from nine years
a month they gave her 72 hours to live
she lived for 12 years
yeah and it wasn't a good 12 years it
wasn't a good 12 years so your
grandfather was getting
zero action i don't know i'd probably do
whatever he wanted to
[Laughter]
see you can't even help yourself this is
exactly what i was saying earlier
mama roll it over put that [ __ ] goose
up in the air
grandpa's coming in you can hot you can
hide the [ __ ] cannolis
but you're not hiding that [ __ ]
goomba
the goose hey
that's when you know you're done when
you hit the gaga get on oh it's broad
i wanna [ __ ] do you [ __ ] inside of
her my brother
i don't know if she's mourning cause of
the aneurysm because i'm hitting the
[Music]
gaga
oh it's awful my buddy was a good
looking guy
and the the judge was a was a woman
and when the guy read that you know
locked me up i'm [ __ ] up and he wasn't
the brightest guy and he just kind of
when he went like
he's like put his head down like that
and he was you know a little pound puppy
[ __ ] looking dude and uh she
uh she she gave him like a lighter
sentence and because he was good-looking
i think so yeah i mean that all plays in
that's why ugly people are complaining
so much like
they they won't take the time to develop
a [ __ ] personality what about
meditating you ever meditate
yeah but i find the guy's voice is
[ __ ] annoying you don't have to
listen
shut up
[Laughter]
did you have you been at the store when
israeli death squad fans come over
have you seen them at the store yes they
are remember the people you called me
and said they were waiting for you i got
stuck at that [ __ ] young movie
premiere
remember those are israelis yeah when
israelis come to the store
you better be prepared they [ __ ] come
heavy duty to the store i've been up
there a couple tuesdays and three of
them have stuff up on me
we're from israel where's the flying jew
we want them
where's the stars of dad they're [ __ ]
nuts
you gotta love them you gotta love them
at the they were comics
from listening to broken experience they
started doing comedy
i guess israel's got a big comedy scene
there's starting now
she's starting and they [ __ ] want to
be rough comics so the one kid's like
i'm trying to do [ __ ] hitler jokes
and they're throwing and they're
throwing me out of all these places
i'm [ __ ] out i'm a holland people
like what is he talking about
he's like i'm doing [ __ ] these dirty
hitler jokes and they're israeli people
throwing me out of restaurants and [ __ ]
because i'm coming to america to do
hitler
[Laughter]
nothing but heart these [ __ ]
i'm sitting there going
oh no where's the flying jew we wanna
made up
i'm coming to america to do hitler's
show oh my god he was pissed this kid he
was doing
he was serious he's like dawg i'm my
colleague's a little rough
he goes i'm up there doing [ __ ] nazi
jokes told me out of the comedy bad
years
then do more like everybody at my school
say you a snitch i said [ __ ] them i whip
them white boy's ass
cause i called i called all the parents
over i called all the parents i said
over here smoking weed and looking at
some little white girl [ __ ] on the
phone i said juma are you black you know
how much time you need
for this white [ __ ] floating on these
phones oh like a girl from the school
yeah yeah you can get in trouble for
that so i put the i put the
i i chromecast the picture and i called
all the parents like who white baby
[ __ ]
oh my god you put it on the tv yeah i
put on tv they was
pissed off at me look keep these [ __ ]
away from june bugs
in 10th grade these little dick is real
real small right now
trying to kill my baby trying to get my
baby locked up for some white [ __ ] dude
you don't [ __ ] with white [ __ ] you
ain't got enough dick and you ain't got
enough sense oh my god
so so you had the parents come over and
you had it on the television
what the [ __ ] did they say i can't
believe you did this what the [ __ ] you
mean it was on their phone
your son looking at it too they stormed
up out of there
they wouldn't speak to me and no no [ __ ]
yeah i don't need no friends
oh my god i said don't you ever in your
life violate no girl she gave to one of
the football players he just passed it
around every verse
yeah and i saw him i said junebug think
about d was your sister garriana
he's like mama get around ain't getting
naked and they did can nobody see
nothing
oh jesus yeah
but that's just the stuff i went through
but then i was like okay cool when i'm
on tour and here when i'm on tour in
europe
i'll [ __ ] put weed in the condom tie
it in a knot and
it'll be like a skit where i film it's
an international drug smuggler skit i'll
do it in one country and i'll fly to the
other country and [ __ ] it out
right and uh and i did it was this
[ __ ] song i actually have a [ __ ]
epic
like uh there's a huge like tent pull a
bit in my stand up right now about that
whole
i got arrested for international drug
smuggling in sweden
um did you i did it was [ __ ] epic
it's so classic dude
because of swallowing a condom with pot
greatest [ __ ] story ever dude
it's so [ __ ] awesome yeah i like it
yeah it was it was how did you get
caught because i had
[ __ ] told the the press like i was
like you know it's
my first time that i did it was so but i
didn't so big
that when i tried to [ __ ] swallow it
it got stuck in my throat
and i'm trying to freaking the [ __ ] out
and turn you know
like and then i fly i fly from norway to
sweden
and uh you know knoxville told me i was
how big was the nug
dude i didn't even take it i didn't even
break the buds off the stem
so you just swallowed a branch of a
[ __ ] tree
and it had a [ __ ] rock a hash in
there tearing it up
jesus
in the middle of all this is tate in the
morning and we all look around and go oh
my god
emil's still in the house bonehead was
still in the house on fire
bro they turned the fire off they go in
he's still with his feet up
with his hands crossed just heroined out
of his mouth watching tv
he slept through the fire oh my god
everything when they woke him up he goes
like my fries ready
this is how crazy this family was all my
fries ready
we have two [ __ ] battalions out there
we got half of 9 11 out here oh my god
and you're still [ __ ] sleeping
you